do what is necessary to be resilient you
know life is filled with disappointments
I don't like hearing this that you would
walk away from something because you're
not as ready as you think you should be
get ready but if you can even help one
person you know it feels like it's
worthwhile do you have a terrible temper
no but I do get angry about things I'm
not going to deny that you should take
criticism seriously because you might
learn something but you can't let it
Crush you don't vote for anyone who says
he or she will never compromise you have
a choice you can either be the actor in
your own life or you can react to
everybody else when somebody who doesn't
know me criticizes me I don't pay a lot
of attention there's always something
you can do
that helps somebody the entire
conference Hall exploded in this energy
and enthusiasm she's an American
politician who served at the 67th United
States Secretary of State the wife of
the 42nd President of the United States
Bill Clinton she was the former first
lady of the United States she serves as
a United States senator from New York
from 2001 to 2009. she's Hillary Clinton
and here are her top 10 rules for
success foreign
do what is necessary to be resilient you
know life is filled with disappointments
and you know I've had a blessed life I
mean I'm sure I've had disappointments
and setbacks and all the rest of it and
it's all played out in public and and
for the first for the second half of my
life but everybody does I
respect anyone who when their knock down
gets back up I mean it's really about
just that and I learned that from my
mother who had a really horrible
childhood and was so mistreated and
neglected and abused and could have
become a whiner a quitter on life and
she didn't she kept coming back and she
told me she said you know you can be
knocked down eight times ten times a
hundred times what matters is whether
you get back up when I got to Wellesley
I was very nervous about being there I
thought everybody there was a lot
smarter a lot more ready to be at a
really hard college and about two weeks
in I called Home in those days we did
something called call collect I said you
know I just can't make it here it's just
too hard everybody is so much smarter
than I am and so my father who never
wanted me to go that far away anyway he
said well come home you can you know
work and then you can go to college
nearby and my mother who never got to go
to college she said don't you dare I
don't like hearing this that you would
walk away from something because you're
not as ready as you think you should be
get ready you stay there and do your
best at the time it was mortifying but
in retrospect best advice I could have
gotten you know for me you know helping
a child get health care whose insurance
company has denied his parents uh the
right to get the treatment that their
doctors say he needs is incredibly
important and it kind of keeps me going
because sometimes the bro you know the
bureaucracy and the political back and
forth prevents positive things from
happening but if you can even help one
person you know it feels like it's
worthwhile do you have a terrible temper
no but I do get angry about things I'm
not going to deny that I do there are
things that I think are wrong or things
that I think should be fixed and I am
not at all shy about expressing my
opinion I I try to be a direct person
and but I don't tell people what to do I
say here's what I think and I'm
concerned about this too many young
women I think are harder on themselves
than circumstances warrant uh they are
too often selling themselves short they
too often take criticism personally
instead of seriously you should take
criticism seriously because you might
learn something but you can't let it
Crush you and you have to be resilient
enough to keep moving forward despite
whatever the personal setbacks even
insults that come your way might be and
that takes a sense of humor about
yourself and others believe me this is
hard-won advice that I am now putting
forth here so it's not like you wake up
and understand this don't vote for
anyone who says he or she will never
compromise
um and and does it proudly you know they
they have all the answers they may even
have a direct channel to the Divine so
they know what should be done and
therefore they're going to Washington or
they're going to Sacramento wherever
they're going and they will never
compromise that is death to a demand I
don't know if any of you saw the great
Steven Spielberg movie about Lincoln and
trying to get the 13th Amendment passed
there was just a great movie I mean a
great play in New York called all the
way about LBJ trying to get Civil Rights
passed
you've got to compromise if you're going
to make progress the advice that my
mother gave me when I was growing up is
advice I think about every day you know
what well you know you have a choice you
can either be the actor in your own life
or you can react to everybody else who's
going to try to pull you into their
drama and you gotta just be you know
you just you just have to be as true to
yourself as you can and
you know and lots of times the best way
my mother gave me advice was not by
telling me what to do but by asking me
questions are you sure like what you
just said like the consequences are you
sure this is the right going to babysit
for the children of Migrant Farm Workers
um who in Chicago you know they would
come up from Mexico and they'd pick
crops they'd go through Illinois they'd
go into Michigan and our church had a
babysitting program for the youngest
children on Saturday morning so that the
school-aged children who went to school
with us would be able to go out into the
fields and so I remember babysitting
these adorable little kids and my mother
learning that one of the little girls
was going to have her first communion
and of course they didn't have money for
a dress and my mother took the mother of
the little girl and you know bought a
dress and my mother was always trying to
think of ways that just through her own
efforts she could help somebody else and
encouraging you know me to do the same
so there's no doubt in my mind that she
was my biggest inspiration and and her
example was a great continuing reminder
of what can happen because I'd end with
this I asked her once I said with all of
your
really suffering what made the
difference how did you turn out the way
you did and she said to me
at so many points along the way
somebody was kind to me
it wasn't my family but it was somebody
else and she told me about
literally when she was like four years
old and her parents were teenagers
totally irresponsible they'd leave her
for days they'd give her you know a
little bit of money and she'd have to
get herself down the stairs of the
tenement they lived in and go next door
to a restaurant and ask for food with a
little bit of money and she said looking
back she said I know they gave me more
food than I could pay for or when she
was in school and she would never have
any lunch and never had any money to buy
lunch and the teacher noticed it so the
teacher without embarrassing her would
bring an extra piece of fruit would
bring an extra carton of milk and would
say oh I've brought too much food
Dorothy would you like something because
I I just can't eat all this again not
humiliating her but making it possible
for her to receive that kindness and the
family that she moved in to work for was
the first time she was ever in an intact
family that loved each other and cared
about each other and had plans for the
future and she could see all of that so
it was just a great reminder but you
don't have to go into full-time
philanthropy or charitable work or
faith-based work or politics but there's
always something you can do
that helps somebody and if you do it in
a way that preserves their dignity and
gives them the feeling that it was
kindness as opposed to
arrogance
it can make a huge difference
in September 1995 I was at the UN
conference on Beijing the history of
women has been
the history of Silence many people in
our own government and our Congress did
not want me to go to Beijing but you
don't shy away from confronting human
rights abuses it is a violation of human
rights when babies are denied food or
drowned or suffocated simply because
they are born girls higher conference
Hall
loaded in this energy and enthusiasm
human rights are women's rights and
women's rights are human rights once and
for all
hearing and your exceptions
she taught me that there were no limits
to what I could achieve thank you guys
so much for watching I made this video
because you guys asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of
Hillary's top 10 rules is going to have
the biggest impact on you or which one
made you think a lot leave it in the
comments and I'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon
good